you blame this on Zuckerberg he seems to
be the bad actor in all this the bad
actor well a Mara I think he's a moral
what do you think you could well I mean
listen like a lot of the things that we
have built over the course of our
careers in social media right we didn't
call it social media we called it online
community yeah we had a sense the rage
we had a sense that you participated you
had conversations with other people like
you were all in it together right
reputation though she had we had a
reputation you had to negotiate with
other people you were your whole self
online you weren't just kind of giving
your highlights reels
you know it was it was a different era I
think and um and frankly at that time
keeper were were more whole and then all
of a sudden you know Flickr had one if
you go back to my kind of the heavy good
Flickr 2004 post of the original design
where it was the first yeah reverse cron
was a feat um fee it was a call to fini
and I didn't recalled it you had like so
you had hard so what did you have there
were comments for sure yeah there were
definitely comments and tagging and it
was tagging it would let you know when
your photo had been tagged or people in
your network had actually uploaded
photos or interacted with your things in
some way and what happened on Facebook
and I think this was very significant is
that they meet it so that what what what
got the most attention rose to the top
right right yeah that and everybody when
that algorithm started working everyone
was like red flag red flag right because
what gets the most attention is not
necessarily the thing that you want to
see your a core crushers get a ton of
attention bar fights get a lot of
attention our fights you know naked
people they gave people on meth on Turk
Street get a lot of attention yeah and
doesn't mean you want to do it it
doesn't mean that you should do that yes
and the other thing too is that then
after that after making it possible for
creating attention garnering content to
rise to the top then you could buy your
way there which meant that you know you
could advertisers obviously could buy
their way into your community good and
then you couldn't ever get even you
couldn't even reach your own community
right the P disintermediated you from
your followers from your followers and
then meet it so that you had to pay to
get in front of them right all the
people that you were following you out
of you know connections with you yeah
and you know not only advertisers but
potentially foreign governments
commemorate the Russkies I just think
that it's kind of a it was just an all
of what you're talkin everything you
describe Zuckerberg innovation
innovation so to speak Wow I mean he's a
disaster he doesn't you know I'm not
sure that you would call those
innovations because anybody who kind of
just spent ten minutes thinking about
that yeah would ask themselves the
question hmm
and frankly go through you met
Zuckerberg yeah yeah yeah and were you
think of him interpersonally when she
first manager personally yeah I I
actually met um let me see I met mark at
ill Fornaio yo Fornaio Fornaio in the
generic Italian chain here chain
restaurant in Palo Alto when he first
moved facebook out from Boston right
Sean Barca was running him around town
and Sean Parker was running him around
town and I was I think I was um I was
lunching with him on behalf of Yahoo
Corp dev oh right yeah because my my
company had been acquired by Yahoo and
they were very interested in acquiring
the Facebook the Facebook right so they
had at the time so they said who's who
has you know street cred DNA and founder
DNA who can go can go kind of suss this
guy out and see if you know there's did
he make eye contact with you at any
point during the last this is this is so
back in the fog of history that I don't
remember but I did have he gave me a I'm
CEO [ __ ] Wow business card famously
that was his that's what it said on his
business card which I have somewhere
yeah but I with absolutely no idea of
how a woman I take that like right
thinking so Wow and then um and then the
second time that I then I met with him
and it was funny because right before
that I was I was going to
voz and he and I were on a panel
together at Davos and so that was I
think the second time that I spent time
with him and then were they public by
that or they're just emerging no I think
though I think it was still emerging he
was still emerging said I met him at the
TED conference at Monterey in Monterey
Bay at a dinner John Brockman's like
building a dinner thing that crazy
dinner that crazy dinner that neither of
us were rich enough to be there
no but Brock I'm Brock was my agent and
he like collects the young interesting
kids so he had Larry Sergey M Williams
me and this kid Zuckerberg at the kiddie
table I kid you not I think I was there
- you were there - it I was there with
Sergey blowing fire balls with 151 rum
yes
you okay so that's that was the lorry
park and sure yeah it was Larry Park
they were blowing fireballs rain and
barackman comes out music can you talk
to your friends Sergey was acting like a
child
I cut marvin minsky over here and Ted
Leonsis and Bill Gates and he's gonna
start a goddamn fire so I had to go talk
to Shirley use their eyebrows I'm like
Sergei you're not at Stanford this isn't
a frat party like these were important
people exactly yeah and everybody like
looked at themselves Zuckerberg like
didn't say anything and it was like a
very funny weird situation he gets up
the leaves right and we all just look at
each other I was like that dudes weird